hello everybody my name is markiplier
markham we're positive that every single
person that's ever played this or made a
video has probably committed to the
pirate voice the whole way through
should we wait there you are
Yeah right now we are jumping into water
to wash this [ __ ] off I don't think it
works that way
wahoo puked on me yeah when you played
the music while drunk it's all out of
tune if I play it in the water what
happens it goes muffled music squeeze
box music school call an accordion
that's not an accordion Sharon Sharon is
a woman what do I do with all these
bananas shove them in your face I'm
trying can I shut them in other places
cannot store banana in cannonball barrel
this is [ __ ] what are you well I
just wanted to get more bananas what
come here yourself into a cannon I don't
that fits like a bad idea and okay I'm
ready I'm fine broke my leg I'm limping
back to the boots
been a different game oh well that's
what [ __ ] I think you did toss him into
another game I'm gonna try to skip you
like a stone okay it's over trust me
this will work look it look at my thing
where's your how do you pick up a thing
yeah I'm trying okay you need to go to
your quest menu tell them about that
whoa this so cool oh my god this is
amazing oh this is so cool oh my god
this is the boat these are the most
beautiful waves I've ever seen in the
game computer rendering this is
beautiful I [ __ ] trying it's not
exactly obvious when we're going
straight where are you I'm underwater
I've been pushed under the water by the
boat you under the boat no I'm behind
the boat oh this is so scary
okay I look down the ocean it's just
nothingness where is Mark I keep being
pushed under the ocean I what do I do
what's gonna make me swim faster my my
squeeze box shift that is something
plays my squeeze box
okay I'm climbing back on I'm sorry I'm
sorry like we need a ship a ship basics
crush alright drop the sails don't don't
go on to the very tippy edge of the
front of the boat is that is that like
rule number one that's probably a good
first rule yeah yeah sure yeah okay I'm
on anchor I'm up in the crow's nest oh
not yet not yet you should try I don't
know how but guys I got a question
we got a brig we can technically all
vote for one of us to be locked in there
all right well I'm just gonna go ahead
and say and I think Wade should be
locked up Oh
sniper sniper the coolest ever
southeast how do you know we need to go
southeast doesn't you check the map it
shows you where the next oh you check
the map oh yes
can I ring the bell quick get those
grapevines I need to make some lubricant
[Laughter]
why did you have a stroke in the middle
of that sentence how do I possibly climb
a rope ladder with this huge [ __ ]
chest yeah sounds like musical words I
keep forgetting you don't need to press
click when you get the item there we go
I'm good
music guys
it's so pretty looking beautiful cannon
into a cannonball what did you just say
this is a fancy chest oh how do you know
it's fancy oh I should have known waters
chest guys I knew what it was to know
it's got gold on the edges guys did you
see this one's up this one's a fancy
chest ooh it's I think it's a Marauder
it is a fancy chest I told you I told
you
dragon hide - dragon chess this is worth
a lot but it fills up your boat with
water so get rid of it you need to
constantly like be taking the water out
of the boat I make it my responsibility
I guess oh god shut up chest Jesus got
thank or all by myself
good work thanks man I was looking at
clouds
that one's a skeleton head guys see it
guys it I see it
grandma's head
[Applause]
oh the chest is crying our whole bottom
is full oh oh whoa geez it doesn't it
doesn't fill up to an unmanageable level
wow this bucket is beefy that's what
it's doing right here right here this
players right here right here does not
help I can't see names right here in my
pants hurry
I want to go make sure our ship isn't
gonna sing wait so we can go cash in our
quests now right we have all it's done
so we should go back to somewhere and do
something yeah times in the water you
gotta be careful cuz sharks are coming
eat your ass why didn't you just go back
to shore and drop your chest oh no wait
it's chipping Oh God mermaid no no no
that's a siren that's how you get back
to your boat don't know I shot it god
damn it [ __ ] Chester sorrow I'm sorry
I was supposed to do I even said I even
said I was like I'll stay on the boat
make sure we lose I'm stupid okay did
you did you get the last chest Bob yeah
there's still like a chicken thing out
there Oh No Wade's chicken coop what
happens now is that I'm gonna go get the
boat then I can bring it back oh if
someone needs to Garret the chest sink
your ship shows up to go in Tuesday all
right I'll stay oh I'm an excellent boat
guy I'll stay so if you guys press Z you
can do emotes okay
Oh yourselves entertained kids oh god I
just remembered how ugly I am Wow what
do you really think about the always let
me put it this way like this
I want the chests so we have to go back
I don't want the guys but they're kind
of a package deal yeah yeah we sort of
left them in charge of that do you sense
the dickish this in the force mark I
think there's a great big turbine in the
force as if a million dicks cried out
and then we're set aside I think I'm
emptying the ocean guys and oddly enough
I think it's working the tide keeps
going lower than it was before
wait am I crazy or is the water level
dropping we go to conventions and people
like I think marks like the brains of
the operation the ground here quicker
we're in the island that's my fault I
was emptying the ocean I let it go lower
than you thought it was all right should
we start bringing the chests over yes if
you bring you the chicken coop god damn
I'm gonna punch you right in the dick
yes wait we're I'm voting you in the
Brig okay anchor is drooping there's a
skeleton there thank you guys you left
me on this
and with Fitz [ __ ] you said you were
gonna get the chest of sorrow Lopez she
said the guy trying to drain the ocean
by dumping though I was working you saw
it was working oh my god we're sinking
again we're [ __ ] no no no no no no no
no no no no no or no no we're not all
right just get the ship going all be
dumping it I'm gonna full sail this [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ] wait nobody [ __ ] it
cares I don't know we're making progress
maybe you should have had your chicken
coop that probably would have helped
right yeah one of I did bring my chicken
coop but someone got rid of it [ __ ]
Northwest ramas you you did not see your
chicken coop I hid it very well I mean
weird catch some chickens you make damn
I wish we had that chicken coop it's
gonna be like hey you know there's
chicken coops [ __ ] everywhere for
free yeah I don't worry about that Hey
crying hey guys good news it's stop
crying we can stop fighting now if you
guys if you guys press escape and go to
my crew there's a there's a vote to lock
wait in the break my crew okay all right
all right
[Laughter]
no actually I have no idea how we
released you from
what song is that alright so about the
whole it's nothing from wait wait wait
I'm about to sell mama rotters chest
sold neat wait did you get anything
sold well then that's what we all saw
it's fine to our dismay we got no money
for those look I think the game's broken
oh oh we could vote to release from the
Brig Wow where where this thing again
you happy I don't know all I see is what
God okay you're not in the brig anymore
oh hey what's up booty cards for LIF
listen I like to think you did that to
yourself
whoa I got a reputation increase hey we
got money from that one whoa I got eight
hundred forty four months hell yeah
oh wait now we're getting money for them
so that was the first one okay no I'm
seeing money it's just delayed absolute
zero zero coins in my thing I've got
zero coins to the [ __ ] yeah I've got
zero coins also as well I have ten
seventy three what do we have to split
them what the [ __ ] hey hey hey yeah hey
to the brig okay okay I'll show you guys
what what I ended up happening with the
money okay so you see that you see look
uh-huh
i patch you on you know what good free
great job that's what I say oh wait
combination unlocked Oh what keeper of a
glittering board so you do have the
glittering hoard
wait wait wait guys guys I can explain
[Laughter]
over over there see over there okay all
right okay is it buried
yeah yeah just dig all right okay we got
it
I bet I can see go on wait a minute wait
wait where do you go I'm digging for
treasure guys that's insane I don't
trust you for a second he's still our
boat are you drunk again
alright I [ __ ] hear that you [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
hey wait keep digging that treasure Wade
you got it I didn't know we're leaving
Wade here quick somebody help me get the
anchor back up
[Laughter]
I still say we should fly towards that
big skull like that's gotta be something
right it does feel like it would be
something why don't we go we'll check it
out
I'm steering the ship I'll steer over
there let's do it Oh
the skulls indicate skeleton forts that
appear throughout the world where
players can find challenging combat and
treasure if you see a massive skull
shaped cloud on the horizon follow it
and it will eventually lead to a
skeleton for these errors are swarming
with foes so don't expect to take them
all on your own if you wish to succeed
[Applause]
boys getting boys get them boys I just
tried to do some there we go oh [ __ ] in
there oh we had a lot of incoming fire
should we go straight yeah we should go
for it
Anchorage did you get bounced left and
right I got blasted off the boat use
your [ __ ] guns I'm out of bullets for
my gun oh my god I'm so [ __ ] yeah yeah
don't shoot me I'm dead I am dead
I'm dead I died okay what is the theory
of the Damned
you'll end up on Davy Jones's boat oh
hey I'm back
I think Am I I don't know all the boats
kept the boat is our respawn point has
sunk boat has sunk double Odin
[ __ ] I died Oh yep well oh boy is she
listening geez I can't see [ __ ] I see I
see god it's white pure white in my eyes
if the ship is still technically like it
is it's gone the doors open oh yeah we
respawn at a alright well if it's
between the shark or the island I'll
take the island I guess
get the sails get the sails let's
[ __ ] do this there's nothing up here
there's no point we didn't need to
attack this for it there's nothing here
we needed to attack it to assert
dominance right right right I am stuck
oh [ __ ] oh and into it guys wait what is
happening why I love last words that
doesn't sound good no I can't okay
oh my god I feel like oh my god I'm
sorry
okay wait no guys oh you know we don't
like babysit in the storm if it sinks we
don't have any treasure on it doesn't
really matter waters we didn't make any
money captain good luck in the brig in
the in the ship sinking right now yeah
[Music]
guys you're lucky no LoJack boy yeah
yeah I hope I end up like drowning in
the river
ha ha ha 1 2 1 2 3 magic trick see all
this water yeah yeah let's try can you
vote on each other as well yes on
everybody so I guess we win mark yeah
wait are you in here with me hey guys
yes it was cool to release people from
the break and thousand percent
[Music]